[Music]
so so pitch me i'm elon you know
i can uh take 44 billion dollars and put
it towards twitter
i can uh scrap it and uh put or even you
know make it 43 billion dollars
what what do you tell him
what should he do what would you do he
knows i mean what would i do i mean he's
a physics major he was a upend
i mean more than a physics major he's
evidenced
i think continuing interest in physics
but he has hijacked the conversation of
getting off the planet
which should be a conversation about
many many many many many many different
experiments rather than the moon and
mars
and getting off with physics to being a
conversation about rockets so anytime
you talk about diversifying existential
risk to humans
um someone will now say oh don't worry
bro elon's gonna get us to mars
with those awesome awesome rockets it's
like
i don't understand this so i i can't
pitch elon so would you go i mean but
but again to push back with respect as
you know i always do and i cheerfully uh
recognize that i may have huge blind
spots myself but it seems to me as if
you're going back to 1491 and you're
telling you know queen esmeralda or
whoever
don't fund this guy chris uh chris c uh
don't
he's just
that doesn't make sense we should do
rockets
okay
we shouldn't obsess about rockets right
not rockets only in the portfolio but
again let me just finish my tortured
analogy because it took me like half an
hour to make it up in the shower this
morning uh but uh you know are you
telling her uh we should really fund
this guy you know yitzhak newton uh you
know to get these laws that will
actually take us to the moon uh you know
let's just skip ahead boats forget about
these barks and and uh and and boats
let's galleons let's skip ahead um i
don't know that that would actually get
us where we want to go right because
you're saying
you know this your priors are going to
be informed uh by the either a no-go
theorem that says we can't go beyond
einstein in which case what would you
say there are no aliens
if if we couldn't go beyond einstein
yeah we're trapped in other words
like
this is another problem which is is that
einstein hijacked the conversation so
that now every time we talk it's like no
dude
we have time dilation we have wormholes
it's like we have alcubierre drives
blasting with my laser
there i'm blinding them oh no i thought
you were making a crypto enthusiast with
laser eyes that's right einstein with
laser eyes i told him
okay
okay
so um
i don't think elon shouldn't do rockets
i think rockets is a profitable business
and i think getting people excited about
the future has to do with going back to
the last moment when we actually as a
country
you know
we didn't want to say let's develop
icbms that are really efficient in
hitting beijing and moscow we said
we choose to go to the moon
and
um okay so you know true enough
so go to the moon but stop with the
terraforming and mars of the in the the
light of human civilization i i just
you have to actually want to save
us from ourselves right now
and talk about it in order to realize
how completely crazy elon has made
everyone who listens to him because at
the moment
if you had einstein and you had elon
people would be gravitating to elon
[Music]
he's charismatic he's nailed in a world
which is not comfortable with masculine
traits
he's highly chaotic he's very
entertaining
and people have this idea of like yo
dude he's the richest man in the world
bro
and that's the currency of our time
so my feeling about this is everyone
elon reaches with the story of
terraforming mars with rockets and all
this kind of stuff
thinks that's the plan
and
i just think it's
it's completely crazy to
get everything right and then go rockets
terraform and mars right at the end and
just like dude i just read this entire
you know war and peace length novel and
then the last page you just
[Music]
you just do something completely bizarre
i just don't get it
maybe i'm dumb maybe i don't i don't
understand i don't think it's ferdinand
and isabella i think that they you know
we needed to fund
universities that studied
natural philosophy and mathematics and
physics and we needed to explore the
world because we didn't know what was
here
and we should go to mars and we should
go to the moon and we should have i if
somebody said that our rocket allocation
is stupid we should take it to zero
i would be fighting tooth and nail to
make sure that rockets are budgeted
okay
the emphasis on rockets is psychotic
it's it's like you're looking at a
portfolio of a very very rich person
that's only in one municipal bond or
something
and you're like respect make make this
make sense
yeah he is uh but then of course he is
you know more diversified neurologically
than almost anybody
uh we can i'm just saying that he
doesn't have the right to hijack the
rock that the
we need to spread out and diversify
because we're going to get ourselves
killed on one planet with a shared
atmosphere
it's completely unreasonable for him
it's wonderful
i mean i just i have a very clear idea
that he's one of the smartest most
forward-thinking people
and he's got a rocket company and he's
talking in some sense his book
right and no he knows look
i don't know him but i almost
i almost feel like i can guarantee you
he knows better
and so you know i don't want to
speculate on what his strategy is but he
knows better than to bet everything on
mars terraforming and the moon with
rockets
[Music]